other than Bill Gross of Janus Capital
he is manager of the Janus global
unconstrained bond fund with us today
from a Newport Beach California bill I'm
worried we might have a little bit of a
delay here but let's work with it I want
to start with you if I'm a bill on the
point about Mario Draghi if you happen
to be right now today the President of
the European Central Bank how willing
would you be to throw more liquidity at
the Greek banking system well throwing
more liquidity at the Greek banking
system is certainly problematic every
billions of euros that they you know
throw to the greek banks through the ELA
basically did ultimately has to be
written off I mean they've produced a
hundred billion dollar ela program that
at this point they owe to themselves the
funds have been basically withdrawn and
turned into euros on the part of the
private sector and the ECB is stuck with
a tip so you know that druggie suggests
that he doesn't want to be political
here but yet at the same time he is the
central banker for the eurozone and
Greece is still within the eurozone so
it's a it's a diplomatic it's a
problematic it's a legalistic potential
situation that is not easy to forecast
but I would suggest that if if Draghi
doesn't at some point provide additional
funds and then if Greece does not pay
you know the three billion dollar or
euro dollar debt on July 20th or 21st
and there's going to be significant
problems within the system
bill do you think a haircut on
depositors or possibly even a full-scale
bail-in is possibly even inevitable at
this point well that that was this
cypress situation you know greases it is
a bigger country and the problem there
becomes Eric that if it happens in
Cyprus in it if it happens in Greece
then why can't it happen in Spain and
Italy and Portugal in other peripheral
countries and so the flight for
liquidity begins in peripheral countries
if in fact there's another Bailey and so
I I don't think that that's the proper
solution but it's certainly a
possibility as evidenced by the Cyprus
situation
berlitz guy and we were told that it
would be doom and gloom that the markets
would fall out of bed if we got a no
vote we've got a decisive no vote in the
referendum yet the market reaction
stunningly calm are you surprised by
that yeah I am surprised i mean sunday
was a firework stay here where saturday
was fireworks day here in the united
states a it appears that we're in the
eye of the hurricane i do not believe
that this situation you know really is
calm ultimately it comes down over the
next few weeks as to whether the Greek
debt and the Greek standoff whether or
not it the Greeks want a significant
restructure their 300 billion dollar
plus euro debt the troika does not and
so the troika believes it right off you
know prime is primarily government and
supranational II own debt they believe
that will set a precedent for other
peripherals and the Greeks claim that
the write-offs in many countries are
inevitable actually I think and I am on
the side of the the Greeks here the
Germans are being disingenuous with
their portion of the debt because
they've had massive restructuring of
their own debt after World War one then
after World War two when an accord in
the early 1950s reduced their debt from
100 to twenty percent of GDP so the
German example of which they claim you
know should not be applied to the Greeks
has been their historical experience
over the past hundred years well the
bill to that point Germany has shown no
willingness to undertake a Marshall Plan
like solution for the situation that the
Greeks confront if that continues to be
the case again the focus will shift to
Draghi there's much expectation that the
Greek crisis go is going to test the
draghi's resolve to backstop the rest of
peripheral Europe does that create some
trading opportunities yeah I think it
does and I think that's what we're
seeing this morning with the hurricane
that I suggested in the eye of the
hurricane you're seeing massive support
behind the scenes of course on the part
of the ECB or seeing massive support by
the Chinese in terms of their stock
market you're seeing basically
central government's throwing everything
they have at the markets and keeping
them calm ultimately though you know did
Draghi has to wonder whether the
purchase of Spanish debt and Italian
debt you know leads to the same type of
conclusion down the road as what perhaps
is beginning with with the Greek example
the ECB is owed as I've mentioned over
100 billion euros by the Greek banks
which appear to be in insolvent and to
the extent that they continue this
program of ela for other peripherals
then you know perhaps down the road you
have the same situation so that the
eurozone the euro union you know
certainly is at risk here in terms of
their arrangement with a central bank
that at some point has been unwilling to
extend additional credit to one of their
creditor and in member countries namely
Greece bill and I have to jump on your
point about Chinese stocks it was back
on june the 3rd that you tweeted ups up
next the china shenzhen index you were
talking about a potential short but at
that point you said not just yet did you
end up shorting chinese stocks did you
get it in time to if you will enjoy the
dramatic breathtaking declines in
volatility we've seen since then well I
did come public and say short you know
the Chinese stock market through a
barons recommendation that they came
public about four weeks ago so I'm on
record as you know having reached that
point in terms of the Chinese stock
market where we go from here since the
market is down twenty to twenty-five
percent from that point it's hard to say
like I say the Chinese authorities
through increased margin and through
increased regulation lower interest
rates it's been a massive support
program for their stock market which
supposedly the world thinks is
relatively insignificant but I think it
is important and you know I've done
rather proud of that call although I
said not yet during the tweet but two
weeks later and a barons article I said
now is the
bill can ask you won't find a question
about Greece how long can you run an
economy like this without a functioning
banking system well I don't think you
can and that's why I think they have a
week or two to settle this and the
arrangement has to be you know
coordinated with the ECB and what the EU
you know within the eurozone you know
basically to my way of thinking the zone
has led by Merkel and the Germans
basically have to come to some agreement
in terms of restructuring versus a
write-off you know to the extent that
there's not a right often the European
banks and other institutions are safe
from the standpoint of keeping their
debt not only to the Greeks but to the
you know the institution's the SF and
the and so on on the books but you know
to the extent that there's a
restructuring that favors them to the
extent that there's a write-off that
does not I think Greek will want to
write off I think the Germans and you
know the EU will want eventually a
restructuring but it has to be done
within the next two weeks July 21st is
the key date if the Greeks do not meet a
three billion euro payment at that point
then basically the ELA the hundred
billion dollars worth of funds you know
extended to Greek banks to the ELA will
have to be declared in default because
the ECB cannot lend unda faulted
collateral
build very quickly before we go is it
Greg's it if you will a or so-called
Greg's at an exit of Greece from the
eurozone your base case scenario for
this country right now yeah I think it
is you know seventy to eighty percent
and again it depends upon whether the
Germans are willing to concede that you
know perhaps austerity to the extent
that they have enforced it in Greece and
to the extent that restructuring or debt
write-offs you know our necessity in the
next few weeks which will be hard to
agree upon with all the EU members you
know it's a German lead decision you
know they suggested it's in the Greek
hands but I think it's in the German
hints and to the extent that the Germans
are unwilling to come off of their
position and to extend their marginal
line I think a grexit is a seventy to
eighty percent probability bill it's
amazing how distance can provide clarity
to a situation like this we thank you so
much that is Bill Gross a Janus Capital
manager of the Janus global
unconstrained bond fund